climate change
has always been exposing us to toxic
chemicals and
things like that
and so
what you you can only
measure what you track you can only
address what you can measure and we're
not currently
tracking
the externalities that we're exposed to
from climate change and things like that
from our everyday life that actually
increase burden of disease that affect
patient outcomes and so that's really
the message that i talk about in my book
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret court ventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc birthright excel j impact leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today is all about care population and
how do we make a significant impact on
the world meet or vashi bhaknagar mba
she's a health care executive whose
career spends clinical care research
advocacy and strategy and operations
consulting for leading healthcare
organizations as a mission-driven
population health and sustainability
expert she has over a decade of
healthcare leadership experience working
with clients to advance health outcomes
in underserved communities leveraging
advanced analytics and strategy to
address barriers to care advancing
health equity and improving access to
life-altering high-quality care
bhatnagar holds an mba from yale
university and a doctorate of physical
therapy from boston university she
believes global wellness can be achieved
through sustained and intentional
investment in products and processes
that are designed to be inherently
sustainable and capturing value from the
triple bottom line advantages that
sustainability offers
thank you very very much for being here
ravashi and you know we we're we're
gonna have such a fun time talking about
your why and you're dealing with such
fascinating subjects in leadership and
sustainability and healthcare and their
intersection
both in and out of your of of your work
and so it's it you know a lot to uncover
here but avashi tell me a little bit
about sort of how how is healthcare and
sustainability been a part of your life
why are these two elements that are that
are very center to sort of your work
yeah absolutely um
i'll say broadly
uh climate change is a public health
crisis
and uh
although not
part of mainstream communication yet and
i think that's what we're trying to
affect is that um
climate change is sending our kids to
the emergency room it's making
all of us sicker whether you're thinking
about it in terms of air quality and
things like that or you think about the
externalities of our economic activities
and how
exposure to toxic chemicals and things
like that over our lifespan introduces
various you know
toxins into our system and microplastics
and therefore increases burden of
disease right and so
uh
so i think that's the
central theme or my mission statement
professionally is to
uh
affect a change
um
in the way we operate in healthcare
to take a leading role in addressing
climate change
because it does have a significant
health impact and so it needs to be
recognized more broadly as a as a public
health crisis
um so that's one um and i'll say
personally um or rather professionally
in my day-to-day life um really my focus
is at the intersection of i'd say data
analytics and population health which is
basically
uh
looking at large data sets of
populations and understanding their
trends for disease their risk factors
how we can affect change um
would upfronting you know lifestyle
modification
choices and things like that um
improve their overall well-being would
providing prescriptions for social
determiners of health would addressing
health equity
help improve their outcomes
would um more specific things like
catching you know if we're seeing trends
for
uh onset of certain diseases um and
perhaps a person hasn't been or that
population subset hasn't been diagnosed
with that yet but we see
trends towards that direction can
upfronting a visit with their doctor or
um can
interaction with a pharmacist uh
change the course of their case
management or care management
rather so these are broadly the
big issues that i focus on and i think
the healthcare industry is doing a great
job
of
making progress along these lens now
but what we really need to do is look
forward into the next 50 to 100 years
and say
climate change
has always been exposing us to toxic
chemicals and
things like that
and so
what you can only measure what you track
you can only address what you can
measure and we're not currently
tracking
the externalities that we're exposed to
from climate change and things like that
from our everyday life that actually
increase burden of disease that affect
patient outcomes and so that's really
the message that i talk about in my book
and that's that's my best right it's a
it's a perfect segue to the
sustainability scorecard but before that
i i think that you and i share you know
so similar notions and interests in you
know things that have to do with massive
scale population level impact those
types of worlds it's not a hugely common
you know perspective on on how do we
how do we think through strategies that
will impact populations at scale
how how did you figure out that that is
sort of where you want to be positioned
right now rather than in traditional
care and traditional health where you
know it's more individualistic it's more
on a group level not on a population
level where did that
interest or fascination come from
yeah um it's honestly uh that's what has
shaped my career trajectory i started
out at the individual level
when i started my career
i was treating individual patients
i
was managing a clinic ultimately and
then managing several um and it's that
trajectory that
sort of influenced my understanding of
you know
affecting change for broader and broader
subsets of patients when you start
seeing trends when you start saying
for example oh i'm seeing that there is
uh
you know i i notice vestibular issues
with patients that may have whiplash uh
from a car accident and things like that
and maybe we should
also assess for this and so these are
the kind of trends that you see
when you are an individual clinical
practitioner um where you start making
notes for yourself and learning and
saying we we should also address this i
have noticed these trends in
the past x years of my practice and i've
read research papers that advise we look
into
topic abc during an assessment but i
think that opportunity to scale out even
further and zoom out and say
wow
uh
this person is part of a broader
population and not only are they
affected by you know their particular
disease condition and their
collaboratives but also there's other
factors like social and environmental
numbness health there's health equity
issues that you
may not recognize when you are at the
ground level
and so i found that exciting um i loved
the fact that i was i had that ground
level experience and the interaction for
a long time with my patients because it
helped me better design care at the 50
000 foot level um
and so that's just it helped me find
purpose or renewed purpose in what i was
doing um and found it very
intellectually stimulating to see how we
can better design care for larger
subsets of the population and really
look at things like
what will
care management look like 50 to 100
years from now what will health care
systems look like how will payers be
thinking about all of this right right
the exciting thing is to be able to
design the future or attempt to design
the future in some way so that it's
better than what we have now
i love that so
let's talk a little bit about strategies
for
scaling sustainability you may you
mentioned before
sort of the same
you know rationalization of tracking and
measuring and being able to track and
measure what we do i'm guessing that
that's a that's a piece of it but you
know how how are you thinking through
some broader strategies for
for you know the
um sustainability scorecard if you will
yeah
well um my co-author paula nastis likes
to say we've done things wrong for so
long there's nothing but opportunities
um
but
and so that's certainly one aspect of it
but the others
let's not ignore that there's fantastic
work occurring on the ground and there's
incredible researchers that are figuring
out um how to implement the latest
research um but that said uh i tend to
think about it
in uh three separate areas in healthcare
i think about the payer world the
provider world and i think about just
public health in general and so
in the
as it relates to data and analytics
these three worlds collide very often
and it's really an understanding for
example if you're thinking about the
provider world as health systems what
are some of the solutions we can
start to implement now that will really
create
a robust business case for change that
will prove to leadership and to patients
and providers that you know
being sustainable is the way to go and
so for example when you think about
green anesthesia you know um it's
actually there's there's fantastic work
occurring in the space at the university
of utah and young haven um
but uh in specific cases we found that
um
uh
there are many metrics that actually
are the same as or surpass what
traditional anesthesia would be able to
do in terms of actual performance
whether it's wake up time and things
like that you know the pain relieving
factor and things like that um but also
these gases are green and so once they
are released um they have
they're they're benign to the
environment and they're non-toxic to
human health and so
you are not then concerned about the
public health impact of all of these
gases that are being released from your
hospital in the surrounding community
that lives near the hospital right and
so things like that now i have a
question for you
so first of all i had no idea that that
was an issue i had no idea that these
gases emitted by hospitals were you know
a concern to anybody really so this is
new and and i think that's that speaks a
little bit to the magnitude of
opportunity that you're present that
you're talking about obviously um but
what is sort of the process of of being
able to replace
the traditional mechanisms with with
green anesthesia does that require
scientific research to come and say we
realize there's a potential for this
let's invent something new is it just
migrating to another solution that we
know we have already
how do we get to the to these innovative
products
yeah yeah and i'll speak to it more
broadly i think that's where you're
going i think
i think that's the beauty of
sustainability
and about strategy in and of itself is
that
many systems today not listed
function in silos so
your supply chain department may not be
speaking to
procurement and then manufacturing and
marketing these systems can get
inherently connected to function in real
time and update each other and work
seamlessly whether it's in a hospital or
otherwise and so
just
necessitates is that we
all collaborate
and what we propose in terms of scaling
these kind of solutions is saying
have let's have an executive committee
come together that understands the
enterprise at large
and
come down to a few use cases or one use
case that would be interesting that can
demonstrate success that we feel
confident will demonstrate outcomes and
identify the kpis that we will
you know
consider success right and we'll measure
success along and so once those
use cases are proven
then you're able to say okay i'd like to
cascade either the revenue benefits out
of that the goodwill the excitement um
the health benefits to the surrounding
community um
there's so many kpis but you're able to
cascade those benefits onto future
projects and what happens is and i've
heard i've heard linger say this to me
which is
okay we've exhausted our low hanging
fruit now we actually have to do
something about the harder problems and
that's where i think we come to
like the
to what you were asking which is
at some point
um
lack of
information or research
meets the absolute necessity to
commercialize promising tech
and
that's where i think the real
opportunity lies is investing in that
future road map to
understand that you know for example at
e-waste there are some critical
knowledge gaps that exist how do we
design out for certain key components in
a microchip like
rare earth metals
what would be a cost-effective way to
scale that um and and have a green
alternative i don't believe we have a
robust answer to that yet that's where
the research is required where the
investment is required and that's one of
those things we can work towards while
we are generating revenue from
from
use cases that we can demonstrate
success out of
so how do we how do we really
incentivize leaders to put their finger
on this i mean that's really the key
question right i mean obviously you know
the world runs on incentives how do we
make it how do we make it risky clear
for leaders that it is in their best
interest to go and invest in this in
this research that will lead for for
more optimal future through
profitability
it's just simple
um
i believe that
you know
profitability is going to demonstrate
the value of green tech green
initiatives everything that's going to
be required in designing a better future
and so
when you think about market leading
firms and you know we write about
phillips for example in the book um
there are firms that are
leading the charge because they
understand
that
they're doing well today but they need
to stay relevant in the next 50 to 100
years they're already solving those
problems and
that's the beauty of large firms right
there are harder ships to turn if
they're trying to implement
sustainability today however they do
have the scale
and the capital to invest in the future
and that's perhaps where their greatest
impact will lie
in those kind of improvements and then
your
smaller more agile firms or startups and
things like that
can take a leading role in redesigning
today and
really addressing some of those use
cases that are required to generate the
value out of those climate change
opportunities today
how how does your work
uh in in the day-to-day
and you know have to do with this so how
does sort of your own career all the way
going back from your mba at yale and uh
you know
in boston
how do you
see yourself integrating these worlds
together
yeah
um
i see myself so there's a few things
one is advocacy it's really important
for the awareness to improve among
leaders in healthcare particularly um we
tend to believe that this is an
inherently good impactful profession
we're here because we want to help
people so obviously we're doing enough
and that's quite simply just not the
case
and so
it's really about changing the mindset
and improving understanding um
throughout the organization for the
changes that are required um the second
is actually affecting day-to-day
operations and so for example things
like when peers or health care insurers
when they start asking
really important questions like um
it appears that we have a health equity
issue we have surprise visits coming
from a certain high risk population that
is just not able to access care how can
we make high-quality care available to
them so that we don't have really high
total cost of care
this is this is a very real business
case for
payers across the country and so when
you start thinking creatively about that
that you say okay you are addressing abc
but if you really want to capture the
value
you should be looking at social
determiners of health you should be
looking at the things that this
population is exposed to that's what's
going to refine your metrics on
what is the true risk of this population
subset and what are the true nudges that
are going to change the course either of
the behavior or the treatment right
that's what's really going to prevent
those surprise
big ticket costs in that person's care
i love it so let me pick your brain
right before we finish here if you had
to think through you know maybe the most
exciting opportunity for a new
entrepreneur that is now looking to
start their own venture not saying
that's me but maybe it's me
what what what is sort of the most
exciting opportunity for you today for a
new entrepreneur in your in your life in
your field of work
oh my gosh
okay so i'll quote mark terpening who
wrote our forward who uh mentioned that
there are
thousands and thousands of opportunities
and the market is littered with
opportunities um
but
i
i definitely think that if i was to
invest in one area um or if i was
personally to look into one area would
be in the area of safer chemicals i
think green chemistry and how our
products and processes are designed
are just not looked at either from an
operations perspective or from an
investment perspective um we're not
looking at the material inputs and how
we just assume that there has to be a
trade-off um we absolutely have to have
side effects and negative externalities
of absolutely everything we produce and
that's just quite simply not the case we
wrote a whole book on it and we've
actually identified several areas where
if people wanted to invest in the short
term for near time benefits middle term
and long term what are some of the
things you can look at in terms of green
chemistry
um
to
design a better future to create
products that are entirely sustainable
and we mentioned them in the book
there's some wonderful examples like
staples that bought the sustainable
earth line of janitorial products
they're designed on the 12 principles of
green chemistry a proven use case for
sanitizing hospital systems you can
imagine how effective they have to be
but they also um you know reduced the
they improved the wellness of their
clients uh there were less workplace
accidents i mean there were a great deal
of benefits you look at firms like p2
science and the cosmetic space where you
look at erico vodka that decarbonizing
or basically
taking carbon out of thin air and
turning it into vodka
this is all leverages this promising tag
and all leverages
the principles of scaling sustainability
um to create those inherently green
products
incredible incredible or washi i i loved
our conversation and the inspiration to
think on a global scale population scale
and and and what you know what are you
know really you know with the main idea
that you know the opportunities are just
here it's you know it's in our economic
incentive it's in our futuristic
incentive for our future generations and
and thank you very much for for both for
spending your life uh dealing with this
but also for sharing these 20 minutes
with me so thank you very very much
ravashi and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
[Music]